america's got talent season 16 premieres
next tuesday june 1st
on 8 p.m at 8 p.m on nbc
and one of the judges joining us here on
the rich eisen show
also the host of the howie mandel does
stuff podcast new episodes air every
tuesday wherever you get your podcast
the afro-mentioned howie mandel back
here on the show how are you sir
i'm i i don't know to be honest with you
i mean if you want me to be on it i'm
not a professional
how am i i could if you want an
honest answer i could but i gotta call
you back
i gotta go get like a physical i gotta
go talk to my therapist
yes i have to see how i measure up i'll
look at graph
the graphs and yes and then i'll answer
so that was a tough
you started with a very tough question
normally that's just you know uh
one that said i'm fine how are you you
know i mean but people look for a lie
you really is everybody fine we're in a
world pandemic
there's a lot of crap going on yes and
we always say and you don't really care
when people
say hey how you doing you don't you
don't want a real answer
nobody wants a real answer how am i
doing
i'm chased look at my thighs do you guys
have an
ointment there's no real
if one person have you ever had an
honest answer
to that question you know i haven't had
like a full essay no
that's true this is but that's why i
have you on and by the way
uh you know very few words sound like
what they are
than ointment howie you know what i'm
saying like that you know what that is
you people don't have to say what is
that when
when you say what's an ointment a lot of
the oy words sound like what they are
moist is long but ointment is moist
so they're part of the same family
is there a moist wet family that is uh
i like ointment by the way you should
you should bring that up to simon cowell
next time you see him
and just say that whether he's moist the
last time i saw simon i i posted
something on instagram we were at
actually at his house shooting uh
something for the premiere at next week
and
he leaned into the shot it's so it's me
and terry crews and
uh sophia uh vegara and heidi klums yes
and he leaned in and then there's this
conspiracy this is why i don't know
whether we're all fine
but there's a conspiracy that he his
head
was a cut out and photoshopped in
afterwards i don't know that that's even
a big conspiracy
but everything now is a conspiracy
whether the picture's real
whether covet is real whether we should
wear a mask
or whether ointment actually exists
so you can confirm though howie mandel
that uh
whatever kerfuffle was caused by your
selfie
is much ado about nothing that really
was simon cowell's big head
absolutely you know what uh i'm much ado
about nothing
that's going to be on my headstone
much ado about nothing howie mandel here
on the rich eisen show hey howie i
recently had bob
saget on my podcast that i do outside of
this show
right he told me that at the comedy
store
that you getting your gig on sane
elsewhere
sent like a shot through everything
everybody there that that that you could
get out
you know that you're still doing the
comedy game but you could you you could
be
an actor and how that would kind of got
everyone going
i didn't know that i was such a you were
a team of uh groundbreaking
back in the early 80s you know that
groundbreaking early 80 move
which wasn't the move which was and my
entire career is not a move it's an
accident uh
that was like the i don't know if
i i think i've told this story go for it
many times but
but i was you know doing okay in
stand-up comedy and
stand-up comedy is my first and foremost
love out of
everything that i do in fact the worst
part of the pandemic for pandemic for me
is the is
my inability to be in front of a live
audience this is the longest and i still
have not
you know i up until after 45 years of
stand up
the longest i was not being on stage was
two and a half weeks and now it's been
like almost a year in three months and
i'm
i'm going nuts but that being said i had
done you know young comedian special i
had kinda
i was selling hard tickets i was doing
well and the
normal trajectory for anybody in my
position
was to then get their own sitcom so they
had uh you know and that was a time when
you know
uh morgan mindy had just launched and uh
for robin
and uh billy crystal was on
and all every comic was moving into
their sitcoms so
my agent set up a general meeting at mtm
the mary tyler moore
company and who were prolific in
in sitcoms they had the mary tyler moore
show and lou grant and
new heart and every show that was like
blowing up was coming out of mtm and i
i went met with this lovely lady molly
lapotta and
you know she said what do you want to do
and i said i'd love to do a sitcom and
she said uh
can you act and i said i don't know
you know and she said read this and she
handed me these this
side of you know a little piece of a
script to read
and it was all this medical terminology
so i read it she goes you know that's
very good will you come down the hall
with me and read this for somebody else
and i go okay
and i go down the hall and i go walk
into this room i now know
that it's it meant nothing to me but it
was bruce paltrow you know what it's dad
yes
who is the executive producer uh mark
tinker grant's
son and uh uh this guy named falzi and
bran these two guys who created it and
anyway and i go down there and and i
start reading to say they said she says
you got to hear this so i start reading
it again
halfway through they go well thank you
and i
i left and my wife said to me how did it
go and i go
i don't think i got the sitcom but i
don't feel bad about it because i read a
little piece of it
and it's not funny
what i was reading needless to say about
an hour later i get a call from my agent
they said they want you to go down
and meet uh brandon tartikov oh my god
and brad tartakov for those that don't
know was the king of television
i mean he brought nbc back from the dead
and sure created you know the
cheers and all these hill street blues
like he created television look him up
google him when i'm off of this
but anyway i go down to meet with
brandon tardikov i i
had just gotten home i get back in the
car go down to burbank
and i go into brandon's office and in
brandon's office there is bruce paltrow
and mark tinker and they said read what
you read and
again this sitcom that i'm reading with
all this medical terminology i started
reading it i get halfway through they go
thanks
wait outside i i was so like kerfuffle
do you use that word yes
when they said wait i said it's raining
it was raining and
they said no just outside the office so
i i
stand outside the office and they come
out and they said we'll see you monday
this was a friday you know we'll see you
monday and
i had no idea what i had read i had no
idea what that meant and they were
bringing me back to
read for some more people on monday i'm
driving home i get home
that we didn't have car phones at the
time uh or cell phones
and i get home and my phone is ringing
and uh
my wife says you know your agent's been
calling call your agent name he called
me said congratulations you're starting
monday i go on
what now here's what people don't
realize
they have been shooting the show for
about six days
they were looking at the dailies and all
the film they weren't happy with what
they were seeing
and they decided to replace three
characters one of them being my
character
and uh who i replaced an actor who went
on to get nominated or maybe even won an
academy award do you know who david
tamer is of course
he was the original fiscal and then he
went on to do mister saturday night
uh with billy crystal but so then i
started on that monday
and uh i didn't know i was an actor so
you're talking about
you know bob saget saying it shot a
little uh
through the room and we can act and
comics could i didn't know i could act i
remember the first day walking up to
bruce and going um
you know i'm going to be totally honest
with you i don't know if you've made a
mistake i just
i don't know anything about this
industry this part of the industry do
you recommend a coach an acting school
something
he goes you have just been enrolled in
the best acting school you can
ever wish to be in and because you take
a look at the
the cast photograph denzel washington is
on the show william daniels ed begley jr
uh who just passed away yeah at gage 106
he was in a hitchcock
uh he was he worked with so and i knew
i'm a big hitchcock fan so he was the
the
bad guy in spellbound yeah and he was uh
you know he worked with charlie chaplin
and buster keaton i used to sit like a
five-year-old at his feet just
and he'd regale me with old hollywood
stories but and i would ask him
questions
bill daniels who went on to be mr feeney
from boy meets world and he wasn't
saying elsewhere but i loved him one of
my favorite movies was the graduate
you know when he was saying plastic i
don't know if anybody else no no no
he was the dad yeah he was wearing a
dustin hoffman was wearing the the scuba
diving mask walking down the hall
and bill daniels was going plastics
that's the word don't remember
unbelievable and that's how you wind up
on on st elsewhere so
who so so walk me through before we move
to here and now uh howie mandel here on
the richest show i could literally talk
about this for all day
but so you got a good robin williams
story when you first saw when you were
working
with him or you're on the same uh i
guess night card with him whatever you
want to call it
robin was brilliant robin could just
blow away the room and and
he even showed up in toronto you know i
started up from toronto
canada and you know i i started this
whole thing on a dare
somebody dared me to get on stage i
wasn't a dancer this is in the
in the mid mid 70s late mid to late 70s
when disco was still
happening sure you know and and then i
think that the next iteration of people
going out was
stand up there was this comedy boom so
we heard about this young guy from uh
the san francisco the bay area and he
was just blowing
up all at once so he would come to the
uh the yuck yucks or wherever he was i
saw him at the comedy store and worked
with him many times and did
you know comic relief but just the una
una bashed brilliance of just
whatever comes into mind with no
pre-thought or editing it was just this
brilliance
just you know streaming out of them
for me the big thing was when i went to
the comedy store and finally ended up at
the comedy store
was i was watching richard pryor every
single night get on stage
and hash out what eventually became live
on the sunset strip which is one of the
most seminal
you know pieces of comedy concerts there
is i think that's probably the
impetus for people like uh you know uh
eddie murphy
and chappelle you know yes i don't think
but he was the first guy that i was
aware that when on stage
talked about real things that are
probably pretty dark
and made an audience who comes from
i would imagine a very different world
and made them laugh he had just
he was still bandaged on stage he had
just got out of the hospital after that
horrible freebasing accident
where uh you know i don't know it nearly
killed him
nearly killed him he was running down
the street he was the first guy to do
that joke he did it on stage
he got up on stage with the bandages and
uh people you probably have a younger
audience than this but they probably
wouldn't remember this joke but you used
to light a match
and then move the match along in in
front of you go what is this oh it's
richard pryor running down the street
you know he did that he did that on
stage
the bandages still on yeah saggett said
the first
emcee that he when he was there at the
comedy store for his first night was
letterman
letterman
was letterman with my mc2 yes wow so
yeah letterman was and it was you know
he just driven out he was just a weather
man before that
and then i became you know i opened for
him a little bit
for letterman you know it's really
interesting and they had a little
improv group the in the improv group was
uh
uh andy garcia no way yeah
really even you don't know until you
live as long as i have i'm an old guy
now but you know
on our show even on saying elsewhere tim
robbins
this very first acting gig out of acting
skill on
network tv he did a he did a you know
guest spot
kathy bates did guess like people that
went on to win academy awards and create
other show you know denzel
right before he did um saying elsewhere
he has a movie i'm sure he wouldn't want
me talking about it but i will
carbon cop i saw it with george siegel
right yes
i saw it i don't know why i remember
this stuff but yes
i remember that right so i'm sure that's
not his proudest moment he's fine in it
but
he wouldn't have been with movies like
that only he would not become the denzel
washington that you know
today but you know while he was doing
the show he got
the play uh a soldier story and started
doing that and then
his lookout you know and then in the
summers we all did
films a lot of them didn't come out i
stopped doing movies i didn't want to do
movies
i hated movies i hated i don't hate
movies i go to movies and love movies
watching movies i don't like the process
of being in a movie
i don't enjoy it at all it's like you
know you do
five you remember five lines i didn't
feel like it was creative from
my point of view you know somebody's
telling me what to say
where to stand on a mark i go do five
lines they go cut that's great and i go
back to my trailer for six hours
well they really like to get the same
line from a different angle
and then i was in the hands of somebody
else to edit it and put it together
so i i stopped doing movies in in
like the 80s and just i just want a tour
i just want a live audience i just want
three people in front of me that's all i
need
well you got me and you got three others
sitting here listening on every word
you're saying right here howie mandel
uh on the rich eisen show uh before i
let you go america's got talent returns
on tuesday eight eastern on nbc tuesday
june the first
um you've been a judge since season five
my word this is season
16. what is 16 season 16
my 12th year wow on it it's bigger and
better and more exciting than ever and i
think that there was this pent up
you know uh energy that people had the
last year so people are
they're so happy just to be out and they
understand
uh it puts life in the world in a whole
new perspective and these people just
explode onto the stage
this has been the hardest year uh
through the auditions to just narrow it
down
you know and letting like everyone is so
good and so funny and so exciting and so
dangerous it's great and then also from
the pandemic i started doing a podcast
with my daughter because you know i
didn't get to see my kids or my
grandkids at all so we'd spend hours on
the phone making prank calls calling
friends
applying for jobs that i have no reason
to apply for
and i was recording it all and then my
my wife said who's this for and i go no
one i'm just having fun and she said put
it out and it's called howie mandel does
stuff
wherever podcasts are available airing
every tuesday that's when you get new
episodes howie mandel does
stuff america's got talent season 16
premieres tuesday
june 1st at 8 eastern on nbc i literally
could talk to you for an hour
uh hours okay and i'll be honest with
you i'm fine
i'm fine well once you're asked when do
when do you take your mask off
when does that happen for you you know
i've had you know at the beginning of
this thing there was a
shortage of ppe yes i felt responsible
for that
because i have been collecting it for
the last 65
years i've i've had surgical mask i had
a they took a picture of me that ended
up in
people magazine and hazmat suit coming
to work i didn't do that for the joke
that's me
that's welcome to me people well i mean
your memoirs called here's the deal
don't touch me
so the deal you know that's it there you
go open the case and it's filled with
ppe i got it well i'm a huge fan of
yours thank you for having me on right
back at you
stay healthy and happy let's do it again
that's how we mandel at howie mandel on
both twitter and instagram right here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here